hi everyone this is jeremy schiefflin
with khan academy
happy friday we've now officially made
it through not only the full week but a
full month of all this so please give
yourself a huge pat on the back
for surviving and progressing in the
face of everything going on i'm vladimir
same to you as well um and a special
thank you actually to vladimir here who
is one of our all-star khan academy
ambassadors so he is an ap bi or excuse
me ap chemistry and ap physics teacher
based in west palm beach florida
even though he roots for the miami
dolphins and i'm a buffalo bills fan i
am still giving vladimir mad love today
because he is taking time away from his
own students to make sure that you have
everything you need to serve yours and
so as you know if you've joined previous
webinars you can ask vladimir questions
at any point by typing into the
questions feature of the go to webinar
control panel and after we sort of talk
through some of the basic stuff of khan
academy
vladimir will take your questions live
and you'll actually be able to see on
the site how he works his magic how he
gets his students engaged with chemistry
and physics using khan academy so just
let's start there vladimir tell us a
little about your background as an
educator and then how you got started
with khan
academy this is my 21st year of teaching
and i teach mostly ap chem and ap
physics but also do
honors chemistry and honors physics and
from time to time i teach mathematics
too which is becoming kind of nice i
like that too
but
i i i have been working with khan
academy i guess from the beginning
uh and and the reason why i started
doing this is uh when i finished my
doctorate degree my doctorate degree is
in educational technology and
instructional design so i kind of saw
that this is where the future was going
for us in the location i'll try to be
concise and as a matter of fact back in
in in 2000 2001 when i worked for palm
beach county schools
we created a a
a clearinghouse of materials free for
all science features and we actually
began uh training
teachers in in in science and
mathematics to use the um the tools that
we had just given at the moment which is
very crude back then it was just kind of
the beginnings of using powerpoint in
the classroom and using some tools in
order to enhance the teaching of science
and mathematics uh it was
it was an easy transition for us in
science because we had a lot of videos
and a lot of uh different things that we
could do
that that would have a visual
representation of of what we do in
science because sometimes it's
incredibly complex to show for example
let's say a uh a um
for example the picture of an atom and
people question how in the world do you
see an atom how how do we know that it
exists that way but then we can show
mathematical models and we can show 3d
pictures and and
for the students to perhaps a better
understanding of a very abstract uh
component of science and mathematics
that we see from time to
it's
time
i've been using for a long long time
yeah pretty cool and you're getting a
little love here from april who says
miami dolphins rule
um
or as janet says she's a new york giants
fan so she has no judgment even though
they um tore our hearts apart in super
bowl 25 but hey that's ancient history
now
um okay so that being said um let's cut
to the chase here you know i think folks
right now are hurting in the sense that
every educator in this country every
educator in this world frankly is being
forced to do things that they were not
trained to do in most cases when it
comes to remote learning using tools
like this
if you were just getting started today
if you didn't have the advantage of a
track record with khan academy
what would you do if you were trying to
serve your science students tomorrow or
on monday
using a tool like khan academy how would
you start
the way that i will begin is
obviously there's a wealth of
information that we can find online
and
especially when when we need something
that that shows results and that is
clearly delineated and that it is
already broken down by subject not only
by subject but but also by topic and uh
that it has resources uh that also has a
a a wonderful program um with with the
community where you can ask questions
and there are a number of people who are
involved and who can answer any of your
questions uh it
what i would do is i would begin just
showing my students a
just a basic understanding and creating
a a
a classroom and khan academy where my
students can log on
because it is a wonderful complement to
to any classroom i've been using it for
a long time and i use it in my ap
courses all the time
and uh
and it's just being really a
it really is a a game changer in in the
in the fact that we can deliver
education at any point in time where we
can create courses and we can create
even assignments where the students can
go at their own pace
uh they can
you can integrate into any of your
courses because it perfectly aligns with
whatever it is that you're looking for
uh
there really is
it is a to me is the best resource um
that i've used that's why i got really
excited about it and i wanted to know
more and i wanted to pass it on to other
people i have trained
all of the science department in my
school in the use of khan academy and
everyone is already using it
to assign uh to
to create uh courses uh just to use it
as a compliment for for class especially
for ap courses is just unbelievable it
really is amazing
cool so i've shared that community
resource with everyone in the chat so if
they want to talk to other khan academy
ambassadors like vladimir they can do
that through that group as far as
talking to your students it sounds like
what you're saying is you might actually
do a zoom meeting or google hangout
meeting with your students now and
actually just pull this up on your
screen and say hey here's khan academy
here's what an exercise looks like
and that way they can see it before you
ask them to do anything is that right
right well yes i'm sorry i i kind of
want a little further i'm kind of
thinking of myself from the way that i
have done it uh no no but
you're exactly correct and that is what
i have told my teachers to the the
teachers that have trained to do it the
first thing you have to do you have to
go with your students very easy maybe
two or three days where they can have a
a a a
basic understanding of the navigation
and all the things that are available in
khan academy but if you can set up a a
google hangout meet actually i think
it's called google
they change the name i believe
right now
or zoom um for example if you can use
that and go step by step and showing
your students how to sign up how to find
the resources where the assignments are
going to be located uh but it's it
it it's actually pretty intuitive to use
once my teachers have used it for two or
three times they say oh uh i'm old so my
students will probably get it in one or
two tries and and then it becomes a
wonderful resource once they begin using
it more and more the more proficient you
become at it and and the easier it is
going to be to integrate into your own
classes
very cool and so maybe you show them an
exercise which you can always find just
by searching at the very top
so just like i did i went up to courses
and said show me the ap physics content
or the ap chemistry content you can
obviously search for anything in
particular so if you want to do
thermodynamics knock yourself out right
all right absolutely and then in terms
of sort of getting students up to speed
about the exercises because in some ways
that's the heart of khan academy
how do you recognize how do you
recommend that they tackle this do you
say hey
just go through it and do it once do you
tell them to use hints or watch videos
how should students think about this
well that's kind of introduced a
question because i use it in a number of
ways and one way that i found very
effective uh
a couple
maybe about a year ago or so is that
again now it's a little more complicated
to do it because we're on a in a virtual
environment but i have tried it already
and it actually works the same way that
it would work in a classroom
and zoom you can create small groups
i again i'm not
i i haven't used
a google me too much but i have done it
in zoom where for example i assign a
paper that's already pre-loaded into my
google classroom assignments and my
students know where to access that and
what i do is actually i i
i watch the video on khan academy first
and i get the exact same question that
they have used
and i and i and i use that question on
on just a word document
what i do is i create the actual video
link as a qr code and once they begin
answering the questions and we all do
the question first in different groups
and then we all come together again and
we discuss the question and when i ask
them to do after they have actually
completed the question then we click on
the qr code either do it on their phones
and they do it straight on their
computer and then we can see how the
question is actually done and then we
talk about and we compare the answers
and and my students really really like
that exercise because it gives a lot of
confidence
once they say oh really i can't do this
or oh this is what i went wrong maybe i
need to go back and review what i did to
to make my corrections so it works
really really well in that sense
and just to give folks a sense of what's
possible
in addition to the videos
if you want to actually look at some of
those exercises together you can come
into your classroom so let's say you've
created a biology classroom or chemistry
classroom
um you come into your assignment section
in your score section
and you could actually look at those
student answers as a class and say hey i
noticed that half the class got the
wrong answer here
let's talk about that talk about the
mistaken assumptions behind that and
really tackle it as a class as opposed
to you're on your own good luck
right that's their way of explaining
yeah
yes absolutely 100 correct not only that
but i also like the the fact that you
can go into any of the assignments that
you have given to your courses and you
can pick an individual student and you
can see for change because i know some
of my students they they say oh um dr b
i already know this question so what i'm
going to do is i'm just going to watch
the videos and say look
whatever you feel comfortable with i i'm
going to be okay with that but i want
what i want to see is i want to see
that you have actually watched the
videos because that is the
that is how i am going to be sure that
you you have actually watched them and
it gives me statistics on the time that
i have watched the video so if a student
tells me i watched the video and i said
no you actually only watch about 15
seconds the video that that doesn't
equate so okay okay i'll watch it so
it's a it's a good way to to also hold
them accountable for what they say they
are doing
so it's a it's a wonderful resource
correct
absolutely i'll just call out that in
addition to scoring the exercises you
can actually tell on your end whether
students have read the articles and
watch the videos by looking for a green
check under those kinds of assignments
absolutely and that could even be an
assignment on its own right too which i
have done with my classes as well
i say once i see all the green check
marks and i know you have completed all
of the assignments you need to do so
you're going to get full credit for that
assignment if not then then we have to
go back and do it and the good thing
about it for the quiz is they the other
part that i like about is that they they
self-adjust
they they are going to go with
what the student is answering and they
have multiple times to
you can actually set it up that way to
to answer multiple multiple times
instead of just one time to give them a
chance so they can revise the question
or review the question and then go back
and answer it again
yeah so i do think that like ultimately
the goal of khan academy is not just to
be an assessment tool but to be a
mastery driving tool where we encourage
students to have those multiple attempts
and actually keep pushing themselves to
really understand it at a deep level not
just emotions
absolutely absolutely 100 i agree with
those payment 100 on that yes
cool cool okay any other advice you want
to give teachers at this point or should
we head into the questions from the
audience
i think we can we can take questions
from the audience if um
i i don't want to take all the time
explain i i think i it would be better
if we just answer what their needs are
going to be at the moment because i know
that we have a number of people you say
are going to be on there right now
or on it right now
we have about 230 science educators
across the country so no pressure
vladimir um but uh sandy says thank you
for all that you do you are amazing so
thanks for making this possible um
similar love from april
even as a dolphins fan um and uh let's
talk through some of the questions that
are coming in here
okay so
um
okay
this is interesting so um you're getting
a question that basically says you know
we've talked a lot about ap and like
really making good progress and all that
if you have a special education student
in your classroom is there any way to
differentiate using khan academy is
there any way to make sure that every
student is getting what they need not
just sort of lock step for the entire
class
absolutely 100
because it can academy is not only for
it's not designed only for the the
higher level courses is it has every
single level that you can imagine it has
from the basic levels all the way to the
very very high level ap
and
uh
you can access just any course that you
want also by grade oh it's on the screen
right now you can answer this by grade
but you can access it at any level so
and and the good thing about it too
again is remember you can make it so it
is a self-paced guide that the students
can follow and
in their own time or in their own time
frame
whatever that needs to be at the moment
right now i think we're we're all in
survival mode and we're all
concentrating on
more on the learning than in in the
actual assessment piece
and
but but that's where we we are right now
so it
it it will it serves any any student at
any level absolutely 100 yes
cool and then just sort of build upon
that if you said hey
i noticed that i have a student no
matter what their um sort of situation
is who needs to go back and sort of fill
in some gaps from earlier in the year
this could actually be a nice
opportunity to do that and you can
actually make assignments of specific
pieces of content not just to your whole
class but the individual students who
really need that
support correct correct absolutely
okay so here's a related question from
april
april wants to know how you do your
basic vladimir in terms of all these
videos articles quizzes are you rolling
them out you know several at a time one
a day what's your cadence
it depends on the course again because i
teach from regular levels all the way to
ap
in my in my regular level courses and
honors courses what i do is i do maybe
two or three at a time that they can
watch and depends also on the on the
length of the video the time some of
them are anywhere between seven and 15
minutes let's say so i want to find only
maybe one or two a day because we have
to be mindful too that
their home is a completely different
situation right now and we want to
follow our class because we all believe
that our classes are the most important
classes right and um but we have to be
mindful that they have other classes
that they also have to meet with other
teachers and and not everyone is going
to have the same level of of comfort
using the technology as of right now and
you probably are going through that
right now experiencing the same am i
doing this correctly and the answer is
yes you are because nobody really has a
definite guideline on on how this this
is going to be maybe
in a month or so we and we probably will
be in this situation for until the end
of until the end of the year uh so
face it any way that you wish but be
mindful again that they are going to be
also having other classes and and that
might be a factor on on how you space it
out a little more again i'm cutting
content when i went the first thing that
i did when i found out that i was going
to be um that i was going to be teaching
online i said okay let me see what is
essential to to me right now so i went
back into my curriculum and i said i can
leave this out i can leave this on i can
leave this out the good thing is that
also the ap sends us um a shortened
version of what the content was going to
be for the exam and i had already
finished covering everything so that was
a good thing but for my other courses i
just went with the with the most
necessary things that i need to do so
that they
at least can continue the sciences so so
you're gonna have to make that decision
yourself depending on on
on your experience and and also
depending on what it is that you want to
cover throughout the year
great great and one piece of advice i've
heard from a lot of ambassadors in these
webinars is just go slow at first you
know don't try to like
come out of the barn racing 60 miles an
hour give yourself that time to build
that foundation the same way you'd
recommend for your students
um correct another question from katrina
that's actually very appropriate for
this screen is are the lessons on khan
academy aligned with the ngss standards
yes
yes they can be they can be but they for
the most part they
they do align
and i and i
i absolutely 100 and i know that because
i actually went through the alignment
process when i did my courses i wanted
to make sure that everything i was
covering was actually quoted on there
and but a hundred percent
yeah i'll give i'll give you a little
sort of pro tip here not only does it
have these sort of citations throughout
the lessons but you can actually search
by standard so if you knew the exact
standard you needed you would come up
here you would paste it in and then
voila you've got the exact piece of
content that's aligned with that right
all right great question
one response
um
ooh wow okay here is here is a really
tough question for you
so peter is saying
i work with what you know what are
typically called at-risk students um who
are sometimes difficult to engage in the
classroom let alone from a distance you
know with distance every challenge is
magnified
and he's being really honest with us
he's like i often use food as a hook
just a way to say hey come to my class
engage
what is the best way to draw on my
students given that i no longer have
that in-person relationship to build
upon
how do i keep them motivated in a moment
like this
that is a really really tough question
to answer uh
again
just because we're
lacking that that personal touch and
that that
proximity and
and that connection that we did
there is no way that we can make the
human connection through a computer i
know it's our best and i know that this
is what we have been forced to do okay
this is no one's choice
uh but the way that i would say it is it
is just keep asking your students keep
the motivation keep the faith um
you know
at the end of the day at least in my 21
years of experience i know that if i put
my heart and soul into these things my
students are going to appreciate it and
they are going to to follow it you have
to show them that you love the subject
okay and and that you care about them
and that you appreciate that what they
do
uh and
and you know your students are going to
are going to care about your class once
they know how much
they know how much
how much they they know how much you
care about them and about their future
and about their
their uh and i know i want
and i'm probably sounding very
idealistic and dreamy right now
but
you know that that's just the way that i
would approach i will put my heart into
it and just say look guys you know we're
gonna have to have do this okay this is
just the way that it is going to do
and
this is going to be important just to
emphasize that this is going to be part
of their future that that this is just
the way that things are going to be
right now this is not always going to be
the case
but
just to keep going at it and and to have
faith and to and and just to
and that's a difficult piece just just
to bring the motivation factor into it
again because we're not in the classroom
and in my classes i'm very animated i'm
i am very high energy and and that is
the same projection that i try to bring
to the screen okay i try to make it that
you know that we have to do this for
them okay and it is about them number
one
yeah i actually don't think that's
idealistic at all i think that's
incredibly practical given the world
we're in
to like lose hope and to sort of throw
up our hands as educators
is to ultimately drag honestly and the
whole classroom down and we have to have
to stay strong i will give one very very
practical piece of advice that i've
heard from other ambassadors to just
keep the lines of communication open and
i know that's doubly hard with at-risk
students because of maybe a lack of
technological resources but if you have
access to texts or remind or class dojo
or just whatever it is if you can let
them know that you're thinking about
them and you care about them you want to
keep serving them i think that reminds
them that hey they've got someone in
their their corner of the ring and
that's all every student craves right
now
right right
cool okay amazing advice um here's a
really important question from kathy
because it speaks to the reality that a
lot of teachers are going through right
now yeah i know educators want to go
online they want to do things like zoom
or google meetings or whatever but a lot
of districts are actually forbidding it
in the name of equity saying hey until
we can serve all of our students we just
can't be doing live instruction
if kathy is teaching in a district like
that
what kind of advice would you give as
far as how do you roll this out is it
even realistic to roll it out if you
can't do a live walk through if all you
could do is like send an email or give a
handout that said hey go to khan
academy.org and do this lesson would
that be enough
i find that very difficult and it's kind
of interesting you mentioned that
because i actually had a phone call with
a friend about a week ago and his school
district actually said
because of the inequality that we have
number one in technology and number two
and in
in just providing the resources that we
need for the entire county
uh the county decided actually to shut
down the schools because if
if it's not going to be equitable for
everyone then we cannot do it and i
guess they
and my understanding is that that came
from the legal team of the of the county
and in that sense i really do not have
an answer can you assign work that they
can do on khan academy to continue
absolutely 100
because i i do that every year i say
guys this is if you want to go ahead
this is what i would suggest because i
have a lot of my students who are very
interested in continuing and say hey uh
what do we do after ap well maybe you
can continue and and do these things or
or maybe you want to look into it okay
maybe you want to continue and do your
own self-paced course uh
but other than that i
that is a pretty tough question because
most of the time at least in my
understanding that that came from a
legal team saying
we cannot provide it because it's not
going to be equitable for everyone and
again right now the problem of the
digital divide is is 100 times amplified
uh i even even in my county which is a
pretty wealthy county in florida
we're seeing the differences right now
among the kids who have the technology
and those who don't have it those who
have maybe one computer at home and also
need to share one computer among five
six brothers at home and brothers and
sisters okay so it's a it's a
complicated topic
yeah i'll just give one very quick
workaround um
if you are not able to walk them through
registration and giving assignments and
all that
one thing you can do to keep it really
simple is you can literally just send
out the urls for any piece of content on
khan academy yeah so for example if you
want people to watch this video about
human body systems or do this exercise
about cells you'll notice that in the
very top address bar there's a unique
url that you could copy and paste into
an email into a text message into a
remind app
and that way even if you can't walk them
through the full experience you can get
your students working on something in
the meantime
you're not going to have tracking you're
not going to look all the reports that
we talked about but at least it fills
that void and get them learning in this
sort of period of limbo
right um
here is a really amazing and inspiring
question from sandy
so sandy says vladimir i'm working with
160 middle school students on the pine
ridge indian reservation
talent is distributed evenly but
opportunity is not
how can i help the students that are now
remote to engage in more hands-on
activities with things they can easily
find in their household and for example
she teaches math but she wants wants to
integrate with the whole steam spectrum
so maker space robotics flight
simulation snap circuits
how can she bring that same hands-on
learning sense of excitement and
engagement but do it virtually
well
that that's a pretty interesting
question because i am actually wondering
myself how am i going to
um how am i going to do some of the
basic things that i have done with my
classes typically but now that they're
home and i don't know if they have the
materials that they need to do it and
again i cannot require them to go and
buy anything right now that would not be
fair for me to say hey go and find what
you need because i don't want to put
anybody at risk of contacting anything
or being in contact with anyone who
might be infected
but
you know that that it's a pretty tough
question i'm can i defer that i want to
eat jeremy
yeah absolutely
i was gonna say that um i have been
really inspired teaching my own kids
with the number of resources out there
way way beyond khan academy they have
super simple like do yourself home
experience experiment so for example
this is super simple this is for
elementary school but my daughters just
dissolve the outside layer of an egg
using vinegar right this was like the
most mind-blowing moment for them even
though it was just two things that we
hopefully all have in our house i don't
know about the eggs anymore given the
egg shortage at least the vinegar
and so hopefully that gives you a sense
sandy that if you just check out what's
out there on the web i guarantee you're
going to find lots of other non-profits
just like khan academy that are in the
stem space that are offering resources
like that and i would encourage you to
discover them and then also share them
in the khan academy community because i
know there are other educators who are
in the same boat
okay right and i i guess i found that
one a little hard to answer because i
again i i don't work with the little
ones
and for example for my students i use a
lot of simulations that are online that
are wonderful uh like the phat colorado
uh that is just a wonderful resource
that has tons of different
demonstrations for physics chemistry
biology
but again it's a little more advanced
geared towards the the high school
college level type of type of student
great okay so elaine is going to ask a
really good devil's advocate question so
we were talking before about this idea
of doing multiple
rounds on an exercise so you take the
first version of the exercise maybe you
only score 50
but you say i'm going to push for
mastery so i do it again this time i get
90 i'm in that mastery range
elaine wants to know how do you know
they aren't just memorizing the answers
to get a better score versus actually
achieving mastery
well you know what they and and we have
wrestled with that question for a long
long time even even before this uh
because i i have that question many
times before and the answer to the
question is going to be that
as long as they reach the mastery level
and they are memorizing the questions
then i'm okay with that because it is
about exposure
at the end of the day this is not the
ultimate determination of their grade or
their ultimate determination of the
knowledge that they are going to have
but i tell them too guys you need to go
through this exercise and you need to do
it in an honest and you need to do a
thorough way because at the end of the
day this might fall into intellectual
suicide if you don't do it you might be
thinking yes i'm going to do it because
i'm going to copy the answer so i'm just
going to ask my friend what is the
correct answer but when it comes to
answering the test that's when you're
going to prove to me that that you
either did it or you didn't do it and a
lot of times the students are going to
be pretty receptive to that honesty
you'll say
this is for your own benefit and this is
the reason why we're doing this so
whether they do it and they go over
again and say oh this is the answer to
the question at least they know what the
correct answer to the question is going
to be so they are being exposed to what
the correct answer and the correct
procedure or whatever the question may
be
uh
so in that sense we have to we have to
have just a little bit of of a
what's your trust in in that they are
doing it correctly now is this going to
be done 100 of the time no
but most of them are actually going to
do it in an honest way
in my experience at least very cool
and i will also mention that khan
academy is not just showing the same
four questions over and over again for
every single exercise that's drawing
from a question bank so yes the student
could memorize the answer to all 12
questions going through the multiple
rounds but you'll see that they did it
seven or eight times which will probably
be a tip off of what's happening
um so definitely take advantage of the
breadth and depth of the content as well
as just that first iteration
um that being said i know we're almost
at time here so for the folks who didn't
have their questions answered today
what other resources would you recommend
for getting support um it sounded like
the khan academy community was important
anything else that you would turn to to
get to get advice or expertise from khan
the the community is a great resource
obviously that the website is a it's a
great resource
and it's just a number of things that
that you actually can do
as an introduction to new material
that's the way that i i've used it from
time to time i told my students if you
guys are going to start for example
thermodynamics and i want you to watch
these two videos before you come to
class because i am going to begin with a
discussion of
why heat flows the weight flow
you can use it to complement anything
that you have in your classes
uh again as resources yeah remember the
ability to integrate into any course too
uh it's just a wealth of information as
a matter of fact you're gonna have to
cut down on some of the information
because it's so expensive that that it
could be overwhelming if it's the first
time that you see it and maybe some of
the things might not be appropriate for
your classes uh it is wonderful to use
as an assignment um as an assignment
tool
as a practice guide um
getting ahead that you name it also the
the sap program that a lot of people
know about i guess i i have people who
who i have trained in uh in khan academy
and they said wow i didn't know they had
an sap
an sap program they can follow and
actually assign this to my students it's
an assignment i say you guys yeah you
guys have to complete this once a week
you have to show up and i do a weekly
assignment on sap
and at the end of the year they're just
thrilled about wow you know thank you
for giving us a resource because it was
just a wonderful resource
but these are just some of the of the
ways that in which i have utilized this
and i'm sure that
many other ambassadors and many other
people have used it to have many
different ways of using it but again
every time that i have a question that i
that i do not know how to answer i
immediately go to the uh i go to the
community resources and i type the
question and the number of answers i get
is just wonderful it's very helpful
and people will answer your questions
it's just a great great resource
very cool and i think that's actually
the perfect note to end on which is um
not only is there this amazing community
out there but there are folks like
vladimir who are sharing their own
expertise and paying it forward to the
next generation of con teachers so
vladimir thank you so much for doing
that exactly that for our entire
audience of science educators today
thank you thank you appreciate it
thank you to everyone out there for
investing time in today's session i know
it's been a long week it's been a long
month i know there's a long road ahead
but we're getting there we're taking one
step at a time and the fact that you
shared this time with us today
says um a ton about your commitment to
your students and serving them
incredibly well so thank you for all
that you do thank you again vladimir and
here's wishing everyone a peaceful and
relaxing weekend thank you so much
can i one more thing before we we go uh
if
it's any way because i know i have
people who tell me can you give us your
contact information is that even
appropriate to say this is my email
if you have if you have any questions
you can email me and i will try my best
to answer your questions or would that
be something that is not
yeah yeah if you're if you're
comfortable i'd be happy to share that
um in the follow-up email if that's okay
sure that would be great that would be
great
wonderful well vladimir again has gone
above and beyond so if you have
questions directly about
ap physics ap chemistry or anything else
stem related on khan academy vladimir
you have totally
done an incredible service here so thank
you again
thank you everyone else out there um
hope you have a wonderful weekend
thank you thank you too
bye all
you